Last year, Vicki Hollub pulled off one of
the biggest coups in the history of big oil.
But just months later, the CEO of Houston-based
Occidental Petroleum was scrambling to save
her job and her company.
The $55bn acquisition of Anadarko Petroleum
was a remarkable victory for Hollub.
Not only did she gatecrash a planned deal
by larger rival Chevron, but the Oxy boss
brought Warren Buffett’s Berkshire Hathaway
to the party as an investor to help pay for
the megadeal.
Not invited were Oxy shareholders, including
the feared activist raider Carl Icahn, who
didn't get to vote on the deal thanks to how
the deal was structured.
But victory did not come cheap.
Oxy’s debt soared to $43.9bn, or six times
higher than the level it was at just a year
prior.
Then came the twin pressures of Covid-19 and
a price war between Russia and Saudi Arabia.
The oil price crash emboldened Carl Icahn,
who built his stake to over 10 per cent of
the company’s shares.
In a desperate move, Hollub introduced a poison
pill to stop Icahn from taking over the company.
A poison pill allows a firm to issue new shares
which dilute an unwanted suitor’s stake
in the company.
Hollub also broke her biggest promise to investors:
she slashed the dividend almost 90 per cent,
the first payout cut in three decades.
To preserve cash, Oxy recut its deal with
Buffett, giving him shares in the company
in lieu of promised cash payments.
Finally, Icahn made his move, gaining four
seats on Oxy’s 11-person board.
As markets and the oil price recovered, Oxy’s
share price has recouped some of its losses.
But it sits far below where it was before
the Anadarko deal.
And that is why Hollub’s big deal backfired.